Winston Marshall was a founding member
of the folk band Mumford and Sons world
famous and for good reason he played
banjo in lead guitar but last year
everything changed in an instant
Marshall tweeted praise for a book by
Andy Noe on antifa he wrote this quote
finally had the time to read your
important book you're a brave man
that was it nothing more than that well
in response to that the mob absolutely
descended like a swarm of bees on
Winston Marshall he put out a statement
saying he needed to assess his quote
blind spots and then because of all the
attention since he didn't really want to
be a political activist he was a
musician he left the band
now Winston Marshall has resurfaced he
hosts a podcast with a spectator called
Marshall matters he's learned a lot from
the experience we want to check in with
him tonight with Tim Marshall joins us
now Mr Marshall thanks so much for
coming on that was I remember thinking
that was one of the most unreasonable
attacks that anybody I've ever seen in
my life what happened to you
um what did you learn from it
Tucker thank you for having me uh yeah
it was quite reasonable and reflecting
now 18 months later completely insane
really I mean I read a book uh through
the pandemic I was I was tweeting about
books I was reading from Mao's Little
Red Book to uh Toy Story's War and Peace
and for some reason to my not many
followers this book tweeting about Andy
know the conservative journalist this
book blew up and um before the end of
the day the weekend I think it was a
segment on your show as well as on The
View I had antifa online activists
changing my Wikipedia page to Winston
Marshall is from Winston Marshall is a
banjo player to Winston Marshall is a
fascist not only is that ludicrous but
doubly ludicrous given that fascists
actually slaughtered 30 members of my
family in the Holocaust so my family
know about fascism but um yes antifa is
is a modern day problem in America and
um and I didn't I guess anticipate how
to make the issue was at the time
and they drove you from a job that you
were great at and certainly succeeding
at if if it happened to you again today
would you have handled it differently
well initially I apologized I issued an
apology and I was made to take time away
from the band as you said to examine my
blind spots
now I don't regret that because when you
offend someone it's natural to say
you're at a dinner party you found
something you say I'm so sorry how have
I offended you and then you look into it
and I spent the months that came after
that looking into the topic now the book
documents the 19 Dash in the first 14
days of the BLM rights it documents the
many black businesses damaged and ruined
by the looters and and in the rights as
I said and not to mention the federal
courthouse in Portland being under siege
for the entire month of July 2020 and
and much else and I looked into it and I
thought I'd been right actually these
are serious problems and the music
industry that patots to say it cares for
black lives well it should care about
the black lives because the majority of
those 19 deaths were black lives the
majority of those businesses that were
damaged were the black businesses and so
we ought to care about those and we need
to think about that when we're looking
at the whole greater picture so once I
examined my blind spots and the author
Andy you know the conservative
journalist in that period was attacked
Once More by anarchists antifa mobs in
Portland Oregon I thought you know what
my apology it's part of the lie and I
can't be part of the lie so I decided
then the only thing for me to do was to
quit the band retract my apology but now
I live in the truth and I feel liberated
by that so I'm glad for that and I don't
have any regrets what a what an
inspiring response living in the truth
and you feel liberated by it let me ask
you one last question because I always
wonder about this since I'm not in the
music business how is your your
management team I assume you have one
people around manager agent I mean the
people who give you career advice
as as a musician what was their View
well the music industry is a very small
industry and I would say that it's not
entirely clear to me whether there is a
Chokehold by uh progressives on the
industry or whether there's a minority
of progressives that have a choke hold
on the majority that's not entirely
clear but um there's certainly a lot of
self-censorship going on and that's not
just in the music industry it's across
the creative Industries in Hollywood and
across your great country America and in
Britain there's a lot of self-censorship
people who are too scared to say the
truth and I think that's because you
know there's a professional and social
repercussions if you if you do uh speak
the truth and that and that's a serious
issue I know you've been talking a lot
about free speech on tonight's uh show
so I thought it was worth mentioning
that and when it comes to the uh the
business side
some of them are scared some of them are
scared to say the truth and others
believe that many are progressive as
well who believe that so there's a real
split there
yeah
sorry when I say believe I mean they
believe in the in those Progressive
ideas and those ideologies and they're
part of the echo chamber is a mixture
you seem stronger and wiser for the
experience which is great to see I hope
you play banjo again though because you
were great you are great Winston
Marshall thank you for joining us thank
you taco
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight